michel dufossé l'a déjà croisé berger il
est ses rien propriétaire d'un des
supermarchés saccagé pillé parfois
brûlés par les manifestants haïtiens
survolté depuis quatre jours
cette femme fait partie des pilleurs
tout comme quelques-uns de ses comparses
elle a pénétré le magasin par le toit
elle est prise au piège mais pas celle
qu'il appelle la police saisit rend tous
en prison
ce sont des vidéos amateurs qui nous
arrive régulièrement
tôt ce matin tout avait l'air d'être
calme les haïtiens avaient décidé de
respecter la grève comme mot d'ordre
sauf que peut-on plus tard la
dégradation repart de plus belle
ici c'est un agent de sécurité du
parlement qui filme avec son portable
pour le sorcier amadio juste après la
capture et la la brillante scénario
parce qu'un mec
le bâtiment est en flammes et déjà gens
semblent être à l'intérieur comme il le
précise et même ceux qui n'ont aucun
lien avec le pouvoir sont visés la chef
d'entreprise que vous entendez découvre
son bureau vandalisés jodie en mai -
vince un constat de qui ça l'on monte
pas responsable qui gens innocents cap
époux pardon paix ça c'est dit romain
mais ça s'est fait un travail est un de
dio labeur depuis ce vendredi jour où la
guerre civile a démarré en haïti les
compagnies aériennes françaises ont
suspendu les liaisons
des vols étrangers régulier et privés
sont annoncés tous les passagers ne
seront pas satisfaits air france et air
caraïbes prévoit la reprise ce mardi 10
juillet sous réserve
la seule possibilité d'atteindre haïti
jusqu'à hier soir c'était via la
république dominicaine
sauf que les manifestants ont tout
détruit à la frontière et même certains
bus qui assurent la liaison entre les
deux îles ont été incendiés les grandes
villes sont encore barricadé donc
inaccessible
cet après midi convoqué par le chef de
l'état haïtien les présidents de la
chambre des députés et de la cour de
cassation était réuni au palais national
l'issue de cette rencontre reste un
mystère et le peu qui reste d'haïti est
moribond